hablemos un poco sobre las curvas de
philips a corto plazo y largo plazo
estas dos curvas se nombran así en honor
al economista bill phillips quien
observó en la década de los 50 lo que
parecía una relación inversa entre la
inflación y la tasa de desempleo el
estudio el conjunto de datos de varias
décadas en reino unido en donde observó
que usualmente cuando el reino unido-
tenía una alta inflación se tenía una
tasa de desempleo relativamente baja y
esto suele pasar cuando la economía se
encuentra en un buen camino así que aquí
tenemos el conjunto de datos para esos
años y después él observó que cuando
existe una tasa de desempleo muy grande
es decir cuando la economía fluye de
manera lenta entonces tiene una baja
inflación con esto
teorizó la existencia de una curva que
describe esta relación que tal vez se
vea
algo así ahora si suponemos este modelo
entonces se mantendría la idea de que
cuando la economía es fuerte tenemos una
alta inflación y una tasa de desempleo
baja mientras que cuando la economía es
débil entonces tenemos una baja
inflación y una tasa de desempleo alta
ahora bien si nos trasladamos a los años
los economistas empezaron a observar
situaciones en donde esto no se cumplía
en los años 70 en particular se
observaron situaciones de estanflación
en donde tenías una inflación alta y un
desempleo alto por lo tanto no parece
ajustarse a la curva de phillips los
economistas teorizaron y dijeron tal vez
esta curva de phillips se ajusta muy
bien a corto plazo y por lo tanto
llamaron a esta curva la curva de
phillips a corto plazo y teorizaron en
la existencia de una curva de phillips a
largo plazo que describe la tasa de
desempleo
o la tasa de desempleo que obtienes
cuando la economía está en pleno empleo
y recuerda pleno empleo no significa que
todos estén empleados significa que hay
una tasa de empleo sostenible para el
país por lo tanto así queremos dibujar
esta curva de phillips a largo plazo es
decir lo que los economistas teorizaron
en los años 70 se va a ver algo así
observa es una recta vertical que nos
muestra que a largo plazo la tasa de
desempleo se sitúa en este valor de aquí
independientemente de lo que le pase a
la inflación imagina que para esta
economía la tasa de desempleo natural es
del 4% y podemos ver que está asociado
con un 1 por ciento de inflación así que
puedes imaginar que si existen algunas
perturbaciones en la economía no sé tal
vez la economía se calienta un poco
generando que se tenga una mayor
inflación y un desempleo menor o puede
que la economía se vuelva más lenta y
tengas un mayor desempleo
y una inflación menor pero esto gravita
en torno a la curva de phillips a largo
plazo ahora bien pensemos en esto mismo
en un contexto de demanda y oferta
agregada en el modelo agregado y
pensemos en un escenario en donde la
curva de phillips a corto plazo se mueve
un poco aquí tenemos nuestros típicos
ejes
cuando hablamos de oferta agregada y
demanda agregada tenemos el pib real en
el eje horizontal y en el eje vertical
el nivel de precio y nuestra curva de la
demanda agregada se va a ver algo así
tiene una pendiente hacia abajo y vamos
a poner el nombre de a y ahora nuestra
curva de oferta agregada a corto plazo o
acpm se va a ver algo así porque si los
precios aumentan a corto plazo las
personas estarán dispuestas a producir
más y recuerdan cuando hablamos de
oferta agregada y demanda agregada
hablamos de la noción de la producción
de pleno
la cual puedes pensarla como una tasa de
producción sostenible para la economía y
podemos dibujarla como una recta
vertical por lo tanto esta de aquí será
nuestra oferta agregada a largo plazo o
a lp
y donde inter seca a nuestro pib real
tenemos a nuestra producción de pleno
empleo si quieres ponerle algún valor no
se podemos pensar que para una economía
pequeña esta producción es de 50
millones de pesos por lo tanto la forma
de escribir esto es pensar en que
estamos en equilibrio en este momento
tenemos pleno empleo nuestra economía
produce 50 millones de pesos por año y
nuestra producción con pleno empleo
implica una tasa de desempleo del 4 por
ciento por lo que obtenemos una
inflación del 1 por ciento hasta ahí
todo bien ahora imagina que tenemos un
choque en la demanda no se imagina que
de repente el gobierno quiere estimular
la economía incluso más allá de lo que
tenemos aquí y empiezan a gastar todo
este dinero y por lo tanto tenemos un
desplazamiento en la curva de la demanda
agregada ahora se va a ver así
llamémosle la curva de la demanda
agregada 2
y bueno qué está sucediendo esto lo
hemos visto en vídeos pasados pasamos de
este punto de equilibrio que nos daba
esta producción con pleno empleo a este
nivel de precios
llamémosle un nivel de precios 1 y ahora
estamos en este punto de equilibrio la
gente está demandando más y por lo tanto
los oferentes dicen bueno si tengo que
producir más entonces también te cobraré
más por ello observa que nuestro nivel
de precios aumenta estamos en este nivel
de precios 2 y ahora producimos por
encima de la producción con pleno empleo
tal vez esta producción de aquí es de 60
millones de pesos ahora la pregunta es
cómo afecta esto a nuestras curvas de
philips bueno a nuestra curva a corto
plazo nuestra economía ha conseguido un
poco más por encima de la producción
potencial por lo tanto si estamos en la
curva de phillips a corto plazo nuestra
tasa de desempleo disminuirá y si
suponemos la curva de phillips a corto
plazo
la inflación aumentará por lo tanto este
punto de aquí corresponde a este punto
de acá en donde obtenemos una producción
con pleno empleo incluso más allá
supongamos 60 millones de pesos y tal
vez nuestra tasa de desempleo será del
2% y nuestra inflación por acá será del
3% ahora qué pasa después bueno les
hemos hablado de esto cuando estudiamos
demanda agregada y oferta agregada
porque ahora los empleados van a
renegociar sus contratos y dirán oye los
precios han subido no podemos seguir
trabajando por el mismo pago a largo
plazo y por lo tanto tendremos un
desplazamiento de la curva de oferta
agregada hacia la izquierda para un
precio dado habrá menos demanda y una
producción menor por lo tanto si esto se
desplaza a la izquierda
eventualmente regresaremos a donde se
cruzan con la curva de la oferta
agregada a largo plazo por lo tanto la
curva
de oferta agregada cambia para acá y
regresaremos a nuestra producción con
pleno empleo pero con un nivel de precio
mayor este de aquí es mi nivel de precio
3 ahora algunos economistas argumentan
que cuando tengamos un desplazamiento en
la curva de oferta agregada a corto
plazo es decir esta curva oferta
agregada a corto plazo 2 esto siempre se
asocia con un desplazamiento en la curva
de phillips a corto plazo debido a que
los precios aumentan y debido a que los
trabajadores intentan renegociar sus
salarios para obtener un mayor ingreso y
recuerda el trabajo es el mayor factor
en los niveles de precios entonces de
crecerán de nuevo las expectativas de la
inflación así que para una tasa dada de
inflación
vas a empezar a obtener un desempleo
mayor y por lo tanto esta curva de
phillips a corto plazo se desplazará a
la derecha así que en lugar de gravitar
de
a donde estábamos antes toda la curva se
desplazará a la derecha y obtendremos
una situación que se ve así donde
nuestra inflación sigue en el 3% pero
regresamos a nuestra curva de phillips a
largo plazo donde tenemos un desempleo
de esta economía y bueno eso es todo por
este vídeo así que te dejo y nos vemos
en el siguiente